if we start like we're doing that Iran  game that was a dream it was like a  dream come true I think everyone's  frustration with the USA game wasn't  necessarily the way to start this that  we didn't change it when things weren't  working and that was a bit frustrating  to see even just changing one person two  person could bring on that energy if  we're taking for me to consideration we  don't stand a chance tonight because we  let's be honest we've not had a great  tournament so far but I mean like you  said we hope form goes out the window  it's a it's a derby at the end of the  day and it's something that we're going  to try and try to make sure that we get  the three points and unlike trade I  don't want to see a draw for for USA in  Iran I'd like to see USA win so we  bought with only whales goes through